I've put together a team.
It's me, you, and the big guy.
No, no team.
Only Hulk.
[FIGHTING SOUNDS]
Now go be a hero.
[ROARING AND SMASHING SOUNDS]
[GRUNTING]
You just can't go around
throwing shields at people.
You could have killed them.
Sorry, I just get
so angry all the time.
[GRUNT] So many stairs.
You were one of the
Avengers, one of the team,
one of, one of our friends.
This is what friends do.
They support each other.
We're locked down out here.
When he gets Banner,
time for a lullaby.
Hey, big guy.
The sun's getting real low.
Ahh.
[GRUNTING]
Just for once in
your life, don't smash.
[PUNCHING]
Come out.
No.
I put the brains and the brawn
together, and now they get me.
Let's finish the job.
Guys.
I see this as an absolute win.